تشرفني سمو الامير باختياري لالقاء قصيده
حفل استقبال
سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز
في زيارته الاولى الى المنطقه الشرقيه
اعتقد ان سمو الامير حين اختارني
كان يريد ان يتيح فرصه للدماء الجديده
الحرب سلمان العرب والعالم الهم مال مردوم
الخيال راع براك في عرض السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
اثناء القاء القصيده
كان الصمت عم القاع
[موسيقى]
واخترتنا نكون من اظهر كما انا
انا ولدت في مدينه العمران بالاحساء عشت
في بيت دافع وفي اسره كبيره صحيح ان امي
ما كانت تقرا ولا تكتب الا انها كانت تعرف
كل شيء عن الحياه تقريبا حكمه اللي ورثتها
عن والدها
ذاكرتها المليئه بالقصص طولامثال
[موسيقى]
في المقابل الوالد النجار المخضرم كثير
كنت اروح مع الوالد المنجره كان على مستوى
عالي من الثقافه والهيبه لسانه ما كان يجف
من الايات
الادعيه الماثوره الحكايه الاشعار
[موسيقى]
هذا البستان
كان حديقه الخلفيه فيه تسكر وجداني وقابلت
الاول مره
الطفله الفاتنه ملاك
في المدرسه
كنا لما نستلم الكتب اول كتابتها كتاب
المطالعه كنت فورا ابحث عن الاناشيد
والاسعار حاولنا احفظها دندنها لما انسى
كلمه مثلا
[موسيقى]
فاضطر اني اسد الفجر لكن
اتمنى اني ما تعرضت ههه بعض الاحساس كذا
يخصص لي عند الدقائق نهايه كل حصه
اشرح لي فيها بعض المبادئ اللغويه
المتقدمه هذه صنعت فرق كبير في تعلق
باللغه وفي امتزازي بها
[موسيقى]
في 2007 كنت في الاول ثانوي كنت مسدود الى
الشاشه منذل من قدر الفصح
والتدفق الشعر الهادئ لهذا الرجل
مكان الشاعر جاسم صحيح يظهر على التلفاز
في الموسم الاول والمسابقه امير الشعراء
انتهى الموسم الاول حصل الجسم صحيح على
المركز الثالث
ما اثار
سخط
الاحسائيين والسعوديين بشكل عام لكن ما
ادري كيف قدرت اجيب رقمه وارسل له رساله
احن واقول يا ابتي
ولست تقول يا ولدي
ولكن سنه الدنيا وظن القط بالاسد
طبعا جاسم اتصل بي ثوره
ودعاني الى بيته
في المجموعه
من النصائح كان على راسها اني التحق
بجامعه الشعر الاحسائي العريق
منتدى الينابيع الهجريه
قريت والتلمست
على يدي شيخنا
الشاعر الاستاذ ناجي الحرس العده سنوات
لاحقا في 2008 كنت احد العشره المبشرين
بالشعر في الكتاب
لدراسه الهندسه الميكانيكيه
في الحقيقه اني مات اقلمت مع الحياه في
لندن ابدا القريه قارب
والمدينه مو سفينه
[موسيقى]
القرى زي الفرح
زي السكينه
والمدن زي المزامير الحزينه
سافر الفلاح
وحلما ما تغير
بس مره ونخله
[موسيقى]
رائحتها نفاثه جدا
ويشتاق اليها كل مغترب من الاحزان
في 2013
ملاك بنت بنت عمي
[موسيقى]
اتخيل وين كان حفل العرس
في البستان
[موسيقى]
نفس المكان اللي التقينا فيه ولاعبنا فيه
لما كنت اكلمها كانت تسالني حيدر خلصت
القصيده ليش دق علي وانت ما خلصت القصيده
هي تقصد قصيده
رمله تغسل الماء
كالقمح ان اعطيته
نيه الفلاح
[تصفيق]
الاحسائي القدير اكرم المطر
[موسيقى]
سيئه الفلاح
اعطاك
غلالا طبعا انا حاولت دراستي الى جامعه
الملك فهد البترول المعاجم لكن اللي حصل
في 2015 لما تاهلت
الى نهائيات امير الشعراء وكان لازم اسافر
واحضر
بمنافسات في ابو ظبي ان اضطريت احذف فصل
دراسي كامل كان موظف شون الطلاب يحذرني
انه حذف في الفصل الدراسي لا يضمن لاعاده
القبول ولما قلت انه هذه فرصه عمر يمكن ما
تتكرر
[موسيقى]
وبعدين ايش اللي يمنع المهندس
او الطبيب او الخضار
اللي ما يتقن الا الشعر
ترى ما يروح بعيد لان رصيد من التجارب
بحدود جدا وقابل للنفاد
ثمان سنوات بعد موسم امير الشعراء الاول
حضرت
في مسرح شاطئ الروح انت اصغر
المشاركين سنا يعني ما هو تاثير ذلك على
ثقتك بنفسك
قد كان اصغر منه
[تصفيق]
ولكنى ترسبت اسفله
واليه
واسندني الى المخيال حتى يدونني على
الاحجار
وصرتوا انا الذي في النقشي وهو الذي يصغي
كان النقشه
من الواضح ان شغفك بالفن
تسرب الى اعماق شعره اخي الكريم لقد تالقت
في هذه القصيده شكرا لك فانت شاعر
المستقبل
وهنئك على هذا النص شكرا
[تصفيق]
وطن كالغمحي ان اعطيته
نيه الفلاح اعطاك غلاله حيدرنا الكبير
صح تقذفون
فان الحوت
يشبع بابن مكه
قرار الجمهور اليوم
توافق مع قرار لجنه التحكيم الف مبروك يا
حيدر العبد الله من السعوديه
وتاهل للمرحله القادمه والقادمه
الهواء
امل الهوى امر عليك
ولا نهي
وا فهذا
وابيك الشعر والا فدى شكرا شكرا لك هيدر
شكرا
شديده التوتر
بالنسبه للاهل بالنسبه للناس
والفائز يا حيدر هل كانوا واثقين من الفوز
ربما لا يعني الشيف فوزي
هذا كان الهاجس الاكبر اماراتي
[موسيقى]
والحاصل على 70% من الدرجات هو
حيدر العبد الله من السعوديه
مبروك يا حيدر
[تصفيق]
مبروك يا حيدر ومبروك للسعوديه
اصول الشاعر السعودي حيدر العبد الله على
هذا اللقب
لقب امير شعراء الموسم السادس حيدر
شرفت هذا المسرح يا حيدر تفضل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعتقد الان في مكان الارهابي همم الذي فجر
فيه
بن ابي طالب الواقعي في بلده مديحه
التابعه لمن احداث الفوز تزامنت مع
احداث ماس ماساويه جدا في المنطقه الشرقيه
هي
احداث تفجيرات القديه لم نستطيع ان نحتفل
وما كان ينبغي لنا ان نحتفل
وقد هديت اللقب يومها الى اصغر شهيد في
ذلك الانفجار
الشهيد الطفل
الا ان فرحه الفوز
كانت بمثابه الضماده صغيره على هذا الجرح
الكبير
اهم تكريم
حصلت عليه بعد امين الشعراء
كان تكريم سعود بن نايف بن عبد العزيز
امير المنطقه الشرقيه كان تكريم عزيز جدا
على نفسي وتحدث معي
حديث ينعم عن ثقافه ادبيه
عميقه تنم عن قراءه التراثنا العربي
كان يتحدث عن دور الشاعر في تكريس وتخليل
الدول نصحنا بالقراءه ثم القراءه ثم
القراءه
[موسيقى]
شرفني سمو الامير باختياري لالقاء قصيده
حفل استقبال
سيد خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز
في زياره الاولى الى المنطقه الشرقيه
اعتقد ان سمو الامير حين اختارني
كان يريد ان يتيح فرصه للدماء الجديده قبل
الحفله بايام استمع سمو الامير الى
القصيده
وقال بان قصيده اطربت وكانت لديه ملاحظه
صغيره قال لي ابيتك عظيمه
ولكن عليك ان تقول البيت بطريقه
تتيح للاخر السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اعتقد الامير كان يشير الى طريقه الالقاء
المتعارف عليه في مثل الاحتفالات
واخترت انا اظهر كما انا
مخطوطه القرى والظلال
اثناء القاء القصيده وطن
دون حوضه نتفانا كان الصمت عم القاع وعن
العيش فيه لا نتوالى كان في نوع من
الاستغراب من عمر الشاعر
وربما حتى من هذه الحنجره ربه حيا عليه
ظل شهيدا في هواه قبل الحفله رحت استريح
عند احد الاصدقاء اللي كان ساكن قريب من
مقر الحكي
جدا
اشرب البابونج
في ظلاله نتلانه قال هذا زين
وشعبا طالما كان شيخها سلمان
تسلم الواقع
والظاهر ان هذا البابونج ما هدا لي اعصابي
وبس
الظاهر ان خدر لي عصابه نحن لا نسكن
البيوت
ففينا ملك في فؤاده سكنانا
انتهى الحفل لو رجعت البيت والامور كانت
طيبه كانت عندي امتحانات يعني وقتها في
الجامعه صباح
كان تويتر شوي وينفجر من اعاده التفاعلات
الموجوده على حسابي
المفاجاه تويتر
[موسيقى]
كان في استهجان حقيقي
وانتععاب من هذا الكائن الغريب اللي ظهر
فجاه وجالس يقول شعر غير مفهوم بالطريقه
غير مالوفه فرق شاسع بين النقد المنقول
والنقل المعقول انا اقول جميل القصيده
لانه فلان قال جميله واقول خانه للقاء
مثلا لان ايضا فلان هذه اكثر كلمه يمكن
سمعتها وترد لي فتره
لو اكحت تويتر يجيني واحد يقول لي خانه
يعني ههه
ترى يا جماعه اللي خاني ما هو الالقاء
اللي خان البابونج يا جماعه ههه
هدف ظهور الذي ظهرت فيه
او هذا هو نفس اداء في امير الشعراء في
سوق عكاظ وفي كل مشاركاتي العربيه
والمحليه ما عاد اقدر اعيش حياتي همم
بثلاثه
يعني في الجامعه مثلا كانت طلاب يطاردوني
بالكاميرات في الاسياد
[موسيقى]
ما كنت اعرف اطلع معي عيالي ما كنت انا
كنت عايش حياتي يعني ما كان ما كنت
مكتئب او متازم ابدا
الحمد لله انا قوتي لا توصف
[موسيقى]
لكن اللي حالي لانه كثير لانه اكثر مني
انهم ايضا كانوا يتعرضون للتنمر بالنيابه
يعني اتذكر ابن اختي بعدين كانوا يرجع من
المدرسه
زعلانين يعني يبكون احيانا ما ابي ارجع
المدرسه لانه في ناس تطقطق علينا بسبب هذا
الموضوع
اعتقد اني فعلت وضعيه نوم المؤلف هذه
العده السنوات انام الا جفوني عن سواريدها
ويسهر الخلق جراها ويختصم
وكانت الامور طيبه يعني
ماؤذي يا شاعر مثل ما اذيت ربما استغرب
منها الكثير
طيب انت متماسك وقوي وما شاء الله عليك شو
اللي يخليك الان كل السنين تغرد
بمثابه
قول يكفي
مسقط يعني يا جماعه خلاص يعني
خلونا نعيش حياتنا
المشكله
لم يتم تجاوز الان يعني سبع سنوات تقريبا
ولا نزل هذه يعني للقضيه طازجه عند الكثير
فرصه للتندر والضحك والقاء النكت والى
اخره
منزعج
منزعج من ردود الفعل على قصيده لاخيره
انا امي اذا مسحت على راسي
جعلتها
مثلما تجلى الاواني من هموم القمح في يوم
الام ان الوالده كانت قصيده
اعتقد انها دافئه وحميمه وانا جالس اشارك
الناس جزء من حياتي الخاص
يعني
[موسيقى]
يدهشونك بالثقه العاليه
حين مثلا يطلقون الاحكام القصيب من هذا
ليس شعر غير موزون كلام فاضي او انه لا
يمت الى الشعب بس
جريمه في حق اللغه العربيه
والشعر العربي الاصيل
الاصاله غلط يؤذيني انه بدل ما نكون احنا
والشارع
على الزمن
نصير احنا والزمن على الشام
[موسيقى]
هذا الذي يؤديني
ويؤذيني اكثر ما يؤذيني ان يختزل حيدر
العبد الله في قصيده واحده
في لحظه واحده
في بيت واحد في كلمه واحده
وتنسى كل اسهامات الادبيه السابقه
واللاحقه
انا رشحت نفسي للمشاركه في حفله تخرج عام
هو في الحقيقه انه لم يسمح لي بالمشاركه
وكان
[موسيقى]
يعني تعقيب لجنه الحفل
ان القائك هذا يعني يستدعي
قصيدتك وبالتالي
انا اعتقد انه مناسبه للحفل حرمان من
المشاركه في حفل تخرج كان وما يزال من
اكبر الخيبات التي تلقيتها كشائر
[موسيقى]
طفله الاولى
شغلت اليوتيوب
ابتدا الحفل
وحبه عاصفه
عاصفه قويه يعني افسدت الحذف
فلتفت
تخيلي تخيلي عاد
يعني موقف الطلاب المساكين يدوروها من
الهوى ولا من الشاعر
كانت خيره
البستان اليوم ما هو مثل البستان يوم كنت
صغير بعض الاعمام غادروا
البستان فصار البستان على الصغار لكن
الفتره الاخيره فكرت انا اخواني انه ليش
ما نحول هذه الارض اللي كانت سابقا من بيت
جدتي الى المساحه للاعب
والان يقضي الاطفال في يعني احلى ايام
عمرهن
الله يستر من المعاريس والعريس ههه
[موسيقى]